si avant il ya dix ans de là où vous
êtes on ne voyait pas de la loire donc
voyez aujourd'hui on voit la loire
c'était des ronciers qui était à 3 4
mètres de hauteur
le travail des moutons en dix ans avec
ses 300 bêtes philippe entretien les
bords de loire depuis dix ans si avant
il s'occupait de 150 hectares
aujourd'hui il réduit la voilure au
tiers baisses de subventions oblige il
n'a plus les moyens d'embaucher un
berger les bêtes sont enfermés dans des
enclos électrifier le berger quand même
cloisonné ses moutons sur certaines
zones il ne faisait pas aller sur les
150 ha d'un seul coup donc chaque jour
il avait une ou deux nouvelles parcelles
et c'est vrai que c'est très agréable de
permettre à des moutons allez venez on
leur donne un nouvel espace de les voir
courir chercher les meilleurs herbe
il ya une joie pour le berger
qu'on n'a pas avec le filet le filet
c'est voilà c'est le conservatoire des
milieux naturels qui gère le programme
pasto loire celui qui autorise ces
éleveurs à venir faire paître leurs
animaux sur les bords du fleuve au
conservatoire on regrette la baisse des
aides européennes auprès des éleveurs de
la région
il faut aussi que le modèle agricole que
l'on va solliciter soit viable pour
qu'il soit viable il faut effectivement
que la rétribution des services
environnementaux et de gestion des zones
écrans sont crus soit reconnu à sa juste
valeur donc que les éleveurs soient bien
rémunérés et pour qu'il soit bien
rémunéré il faut effectivement repenser
dz que l'on a perdu
l'entretien des berges par les moutons
permet de limiter les risques de crues
et d' incendies
l'enjeu pour les éleveurs serait de voir
reconnaître d'utilité publique leur
travail sur les bords de loire